[Musique]
si dans chaque cité on a créé des
installations sous temps considérable
pour assurer la purification et le
contrôle de l'eau c'est qu'elle met à
l'abri des maladies épidémiques des
dizaines des centaines de milliers de
consommateurs quotidiens
des spécialistes ont même la charge d'en
apprécier le goût ce qui n'empêche pas
les citadins de faire quand même la fine
bouche mais cette eau est saine même si
sa saveur est discutable
vient après cela l'heure des vacances le
citadin qui a loué une charmante maison
dans un charmant village ne peut
résister au romantisme du puits où dort
une aussi clair si frêche si naturelle
du moins le croit-il
faute d'avoir fait la relation entre le
spectacle du voisinage et les faits d
infiltration dans le sol et c'est ainsi
qu'on constate toujours après les
vacances une recrudescence de typhoïde
car rien n'est plus trompeur qu'une eau
fraîche est limpide il suffit de la
regarder au microscope dans un village
sans adduction d'eau remettez vous en
donc à l'appareil purificateur à ausone
mais si vous êtes campeurs et tenter par
l'eau d'une source qui chantent au creux
des rochers il n'est bien sûr pas
question d'apporter toute une
installation de purification
voici alors une recette dont
l'application est des plus sains
quelques gouttes d'eau de javel dans 10
litres d'eau agitée avec un simple bâton
doit conserver soigneusement propres
laisser reposer une demi heure pour que
le chlore et le temps d'agir
vous pouvez boire alors avec
tranquillité amateurs de vieilles fermes
de boisés de ruisseaux dites vous que
les charmes de la nature ne sont que ce
qu'ils sont ne gâchez pas vos vacances
par un accès de romantisme à considérer
la civilisation de l'eau de javel a du
bon
[Musique]